right
we've been throwing that then on the
side straight across and I got screen on
eBay tried fit in it and it it sort of
worked as a fashion one right
I've been successfully with the phone a
couple of no iPhone
I'll stop with the iPhone people the
other phones that can do better things
nowadays
get started then good evening everybody
and welcome to our Development Committee
on the 21st of November 2019 begin with
our usual emergency evacuation
announcement first should we be required
to evacuate the building would you
please leave the building via the
nearest available exit of the chamber or
assembly point is in the public carpark
at the side of the Civic suite please
don't delay your evacuation to collect
any belongings please don't return into
the building until given permission to
do so by council staff please note that
the meeting will be audio recorded and
with your mobile police turn it to
silent or off thank you very much this
royal visitors this evening the the way
the way things work is that an item will
be presented by the officers then anyone
that has pre-registered to speak will be
given a maximum of five minutes to speak
from the front then it'll be for any of
our non-committee members counselors who
are non committee members to put an
input and then it will go to the members
of the committee to discuss and
ultimately come up with a decision item
one apologies for absence there are none
our substitute members therefore there
are non or non members attending we have
counselor my own counselor Steptoe
counselor our no counsel McPherson and
counselor Mason so that takes us on two
minutes of the meeting held on the 17th
october 2019
we'd be happy for me to sign those as a
correct and accurate record of that
meeting thank you very much declarations
of interest against the Weston
okay thank you
Alice let mrs. Mason you thank you
that's a melon yeah okay thank you
right thank you very much for that our
first two items are carried over from
the previous meeting when we had our
unfortunate IT issues and so it's item 6
which is land adjacent to 34 mount
crescent Hockley thank you Kevin and
this application relates to 34 Mount
Pleasant and as you can see from the
image in front of you and the
application site is situated on a corner
plot sits right on the cornflour along
mount Crescent and hopefully planning
permission is being sought to subdivide
the plot and narrator to attach to bed
bungalow a vehicle crossover is proposed
on to mount Crescent two-car parking
spaces would be laid out some front of
each dwelling and a private amenity
space to serve the proposed dwelling
just going to show you the the
application plan and police relates the
proposed bungalow itself it's considered
that the scale bulk layout and height an
appearance of the proposed dwelling is
comparable compatible to surrounding
properties within the street scene it's
also considered that the scowl and
distance from the proposed well into the
existing surrounded Whelan's
is not considered to have an impact upon
neighboring properties in terms of
overlooking overshadowing and moving on
to the actual vehicle access and car
parking itself to the property and this
is site plan which shows you the
existing property which is number 34
Mount Crescent and it shows you two car
parking spaces to the front of that
property and the site H team red is the
proposed dwelling which shows two
vehicle parking spaces to the front of
that dwelling it also shows the existing
crossover to be retained which the
proposed dwelling would use and then
there's a proposed crossbow which
crossover which would serve the existing
dwelling so they use that turn into park
their cars on on the front and hobbies
have Benedict and consulted initially
they objected to the proposal as the
development was only showing the
existing crossover not proposed
crossover
however these plan this plan here in
front of you is an additional plan which
has been revised and shows you that Ana
crossover has been proposed served the
existing dwelling so they no longer
raise any objections to this proposal
and therefore the application has been
recommended for an approval subject to
conditions thank you thank you two
speakers registered on this
just to reiterate the points made by
their the comments raised by councillor
Yves in regards the application related
to a previously issued document by
highways what's been superseded the
document issue was incorrect due to a
mistake or miscommunication between this
has since been rectified and a new
document issued by highways etics
highways and the senior planners are now
an agreement that the application is
policy compliant I would like to ask all
the committee members to please look at
the documentation issued not the
documents issued in in error so thank
you the National Planning policy
framework requires good design for an
infield positively contributing to
making the estate better for existing
residents the effective use of land in
meeting the need for homes lost
maintaining desirability preservation of
an areas prevailing character and
setting including residential gardens
the situation of the proposed
development on the corner plot does not
meet these requirements because there's
not enough space to accommodate the
building without extending past the
existing building lines on both sides of
the bends and awkward position of the
building on the plot impacting the
outlook or current outlook of number 32
and line of sight around the bend if the
existing property had applied for
planning it probably wouldn't have been
allowed because it would have been more
than 50% of the curtilage the developer
said he was erecting a security fence
during the development which he did to
the front aspect but replaced the
existing 3/4 brick wall with a six-foot
concrete wood fence to the boundary
adjacent to the highway and immediately
in front of the existing rear boundary
fence of number 32 blocking outlook and
light into their kitchen
Town and Country Planning order does not
permit a fence adjacent to highway
including the depth of any pathway to be
more than one meter without planning
permission and if it creates an
obstruction to the view of persons use
in the highway as to be likely to cause
danger to such persons it should be
refused which this does and there are
case stated for this the position in the
building would still reduce line of
sight around the bend if the fence was
reduced to a meter there is insufficient
frontage to accommodate the two vehicles
access in any key grissini independently
using the vehicle access having to
reverse onto the road on the bend
there's a covenant on the land tire to
effect in the land plots of men Crescent
stating no building to take place within
12 foot of the road a covenants checked
as part of planning
if so counsel should know about it if
not if it's broken they could be liable
the developer has already put in the
drainage for the new build which makes
it indicate that they think they're
going to get planning permission unsafe
accessed [ __ ] yes highways did object
originally and they objected because of
the lack of space to maneuver oblique
vehicle maneuvers with restricted
visibility and it would set a precedent
slated to inappropriate parking
detriment with a general safety of all
highway users and principle of
discouraging on street parking in the
locality the derelict permitted the new
plan retaining the existing drop curb
for the new built and proposed a second
for this existing house the highways
have approved this with three conditions
but did not explain how it mitigated the
reasons for their early on fusil a
revised explanation was only posted
today but it makes no sense without
planning permission
neither drop curbs would meet their
current requirements for the following
reason the new submission states that
the existing crossover in driveway will
be used for the proposed development so
there will be no change in vehicle
movements to and from the site which is
not true because part of the existing
access Drive was retained within the
existing property boundary this means
the existing drop curb is not in front
of the new plot a navicular access
cannot overlap another properties
boundary so it would need to be moved by
two to three curbs towards the blind
Bend a second job curb cannot be within
five meters of an existing one which it
would be both the existing one for that
property and the neighboring property
the plot has been split there was no
planning permission for the second
dwelling unless this is the loop part
the developer commute
having already sold number 34 without
proof vehicle access
telling the highways had agreed to the
second the number of vehicles will still
be increasing where there's one or two
vehicle access because of the addition
of dwelling two of the four spaces will
still be a bleak parking and they still
will be coming onto the blind bent drop
curbs can only be four curbs right
therefore the vehicles on both plots
still cannot get on and off each drive
independently and visibility will still
be restricted for a number 434 by the
vehicles parked on the new build and the
new bill because their proximity closer
to the blind Bend how is it sumptuous
the nature of the road equals low bigger
volume and speed is incorrect cast flyer
and the bend
especially delivery and carers who are
on a clock the fact that the majority of
residents already have to reverse off
their drives is because the builders of
roads were not built with the current
vehicle volume in mind parking
restrictions had adapted by using the
front Park guards for parking but they
are not on the blind bent highways
suggesting that because it's expected
the plans are acceptable is irrelevant
and cannot be used and should not be
used as a precedence and road traffic
accidents do not support their
assumptions there have been several near
misses because of the nature of the road
and little space of time for anyone to
respond having in feels an increase in
vehicle access and on street parking is
just adding to an existing risk how can
that be perceptible highways requires
the building deliveries to be maintained
within the plot that's going to be very
difficult they couldn't do it for the
existing number 34 and they block the
road and pavement on several occasions
without any signage or licenses we have
to ask why none of this was picked up on
the highways or planning offices is it
that they're more interested in pushing
developments through the local residents
interest the comments of planning
offices dismiss dismiss in residents
objections as over reacting but we see
recent inference by this and other
developers in the area that only meet
minimum housing requirements fitting in
as many properties on a plot
okay members just a reminder that there
is some information on the addendum and
a small alteration to the office of
recomendation on condition four kalsa
canal firstly you won't be able to vote
on this one it is misty you know the
format okay thank you counselor mrs.
Mason
you just do your marketing I forget
these things can you hear me now yeah
it's for the record I'll stop and I do
this when it's closer as the committee
will be aware this item was recommended
for approval and then called in to
Development Committee by the ward member
and was due to be heard by the
development committee on the 17th of
October when along with another referred
item the committee were unable to
determine the application due to
technical difficulties with the
council's IT system the applicant was
understandably concerned about this and
approached myself for clarification of
the council's planning process which I
trust I was able to provide however
looking in detail at the application I
could see why councilor eaves had raised
concerns regarding the highway aspect of
the application as demonstrated by the
officers presentation and detailed in
that the report the proposal is for a
modest bungalow in keeping with the
surrounding area and I'm sure that we
are aware that this type of property is
much needed in our district that said we
need to be aware of our own policies and
guidelines giving appropriate way to any
material planning matters I have visited
the site and there is no issue regarding
bulk and mass and from a visual immunity
perspective the proposal sits well with
in the street scene
neither could this be considered back
land development it is not Greenbelt in
short it meets the National Planning
policy framework and our core strategy
as detailed in the officers clear report
I note the comments on page 6.5
regarding the soft landscaping and I'm
sure that the applicant will consider
providing the maximum soft landscaping
possible around the curve
indeed the only issue seems to be with
the highway aspect and the proposal has
been approved by Essex County Council
who the highway authority on this matter
I note the previous speakers comments
regarding covenants but this is not a
planning consideration I believe that
this may this highway issue may have
been due to the lack of understanding on
the proposed access points my belief is
that it was originally mistakenly
assumed by Essex County Council that as
the existing access point is almost
capable of serving both the host
property and that of the proposed
dwelling that this was the intention it
was not the existing access point is to
serve the new bungalow was the existing
dwelling will have a new crossover point
as demonstrated on the screen now that
this has been clarified and confirmed
the highway authority have no objection
and I strongly recommend that this
committee follow the officers
recommendation for approval with the
revised condition as shown in the
addendum Thank You mr. chairman anything
no members Reeves
thank you I called this in primarily
because of concerns that I had on the
conflicting were apparently conflicting
reports that we had the reports that
we've had from highways do reflect two
completely different summations one of
the things that actually does rather
stand out to me is the issue that in the
first response and I'll read you the
response verbatim the plan shows two
on-site parking spaces for the proposed
dwelling however use of these spaces
would be very difficult to do to the
lack of space to maneuver now this is
important this next bit furthermore the
fact that both dwellings would be
accessed so what we are looking at there
is two scenarios the first half of this
talks about the lack of maneuver on both
places and then furthermore as another
issue that they were actually being
accessed from a single vehicle er and
crossing that issue of the the both
dwellings being accessed from the same
vehicle or crossing has obviously been
easily dealt with however the use of the
spaces for with a lack of maneuver on
there I believe is still an issue and
one of the things that was pointed out
and in particular in writing on that
first response was the fact of parallel
parking to the foot way would require
oblique venire vehicle maneuvers with
the restricted visibility now that has
not been dealt with on either the
existing plot or the new plot and in
actual fact if members look at the plan
that is on screen at the moment you will
be aware that the proposed site and the
existing site both do not give freedom
of movement to bow
cars it's only to get the second car out
in both cases you'd have to move the
first car so um rather puzzled how it is
that the second response from highway
from a different officer then comes to a
completely different conclusion that
it's okay so that is one issue the other
issue is along the lines with the second
response this is something that I'm not
sure how committee can deal with this
but it does actually state because of
concerns raised by the residents in the
area regarding delivery vehicles and
various workers vehicles in the area
that they have put a condition on there
which basically dictates that any
vehicles associated with the site and
any delivery vehicles must be cited on
the plot now it doesn't take a genius to
realize that you are not going to get
any of them on the site so I am puzzled
as to how it is highways actually think
that they're going to deal with some of
these issues which they have actually
hired highlighted in their first
response as being a health and safety
issue by actually suggesting that they
put in a clause which is inoperable I'd
be interested to hear further members
comment on that before I'd make a
conclusion if I may go Stanley
Thank You chairman one one thing that
draws my attention is the boundary to
mail present on the corner alone as this
does not give visible access for drivers
in that northerly direction I wonder if
we and I wonder if again that is there
something we could do in relation to the
height of the fence line on that
boundary line to give much more
visibility remember some the the
discussion is is quite clearly regarding
the highway issues the access and so on
highways have looked at this application
and quite clearly they have said they
have no highway safety concerns and are
content though that that is where we are
at this moment in time so councilor you
did ask if you could just finish off
we'll do that and then yeah thank you -
and I must admit this one has given me a
good deal of thought going back and
forth and talking to the officers about
it and I do have reservations about the
fact that you have two different
highways officers who have come to two
different conclusions and one says yes
one says no it is a concern because it
seems that though the the specialists
reports that we are getting are
conflicting and that doesn't help us at
all
my feeling is that there should be
conditions put in here much along the
lines as cancer Stanley has suggested
the sight line is an issue coming around
the corner I have been to the site and
there is a six-foot fence that has been
put around the site and as you come
around the corner
it does restrict view
I don't know what to suggest about the
deliveries but that is going to be a
very contentious issue if this is passed
with the neighbors around there I just
don't see that that condition is
implementable
and if it isn't would we as a council be
willing to enforce and how could we
enforce I don't see that we could
counter Stanley one last time and then
we need to determine this one I think
could could could it be possible to put
a condition of height of boundary faiths
to be to not exceed visual amenity for
drivers I wonder I asked the officer
please have looked at the application
they've taken the the comments of
Highways I'll just let you make a
comment before we yeah there's no
problem we can put a condition regarding
height the fence and so we can discuss
it with the agent and going forwards
that's not an issue and just a highway
issues as well you want me to address so
at this moment you've you've made a
suggestion the officers have said it's
possible I'm in your hands I think this
is this one slight clarification which
when the officer said the fence do you
mean the fence which is blocking out the
lights of the kitchen which is one point
I would be one me told you mean fence
looking rounds it'll be the fence on the
flank boundary on the corner and that
would look to reduce so it'd be a
precondition to say that Vantage
treatment should be agreed so would
members be content with an additional
condition that said boundary treatment
to be agreed by officers okay so that is
in now an additional additional
condition along with the minor revision
that's on the addendum the
recommendation for approval is printed
on six point nine those members in favor
of the approval please indicate those
against that item is carried thank you
approved
right next one is waterside farm the
chase pagglesham who's doing this one
in a minute this presentation first but
you can take a seat
okay right sorry okay
can I bring the location plan up first
in absence of the M
thank you
sorry members this application relates
to this rectangular shaped building here
the applicant seeks to change the use of
this building to form two Holliday let's
the site is to the south of the main
settlement of pagglesham East End which
is just off the plan here and beyond the
site to the west south and east is
arable land beyond which to the south of
the river Roach and East parish and boat
yard the site is accessed by a narrow
gravel track which leads up to
residential properties that front the
track close by namely orchard cottage
and chase cottage if it can take you to
the existing plans so the building has
the appearance of a traditional stable
and it's arranged in a rectangle the
building is of timber and brick
construction with a tiled roof can take
you to the proposed plans actually the
photo sorry there's some photographs of
the property
so these photographs show the general
appearance of the building as it stands
today members will see if we scroll just
down through them that some minor
repairs externally would be necessary
but generally the building is of a
substantial and permanent construction
the building has permanence in the
landscape already for take you to the
proposed plans members will see that the
proposal is to convert the building into
two holiday let's one would be a two-bed
property in the other three bed two
modest extensions are proposed if you
just scroll down on that plan these are
internally sort of within the courtyard
area so I sort of externally around
there the building would not exceed the
existing footprint the extensions are to
create corridors to access the rooms
that are proposed as set out in the
offices report one of the key
considerations in this termination of
this application relates to the
Greenbelt national and local planning
policy allows for the reuse of existing
rural buildings particularly the
council's policy gb2 allows for forms of
rural diversification including
conversion to Bed and Breakfasts and
small hotels council policy DM 13
requires a number of criteria to be met
which are considered met in this case as
set out in the report this policy also
allows for modest extension of the
existing building where it would not
result in disproportionate extensions
over the original than these two
extensions here are considered modest
council policy CTL CLT 11 also supports
conversion to bed-and-breakfast hotels
in the interest of promoting tourism in
the district the officer report made
reference to the developer classifying
the proposal within the use plus c1 as
hotels and consciously offers a report I
consider that the app the use would be
within this c1 use class the proposal is
not for residential dwellings which
would fall into the c3 use class and it
is not therefore necessary to impose any
additional conditions relating to the
removal of permitted development rights
which would ordinarily apply to dwelling
or for the construction of outbuildings
within the land surrounding the existing
building the site is located some
distance from neighboring properties to
the north and it's considered that the
proposed two holiday lights would not be
used that would conflict with these
existing neighboring residential uses
conditions are recommended relating to
ecological mitigation and protection and
drainage amongst other things subject to
the recommendation conditions
recommended condition sorry
the proposal is considered a suitable
use of the building which would comply
with relevant national local policy and
the recommendation is one of approval
just reminder there's a bit of
information on the addendum we have two
speakers for this one mr. Ford
[Music]
maxima five minutes let you know when
you've got a minute to go
Thank You Sherman
thank you I'm Russell Ford chartered
sound planner and I represent the
applicants in this current application
it is recommended for approval all the
issues are set out for you in some
detail in your officers reports every
conceivable question is asked and
answered positively leading
unequivocally to the conclusion that
planning permission should be granted in
my wide experience of this type of
scheme I would say this application in
particular is a relative gem and it
deserves your enthusiastic support it
fuses together so many aspects of local
and national policy and offends non this
honest looking traditional building was
rested easily in the landscape for 750
years it is vernacular in form with
traditional materials and some historic
interest but yet it is tired and in need
of a new purpose
rural diversification supports sensitive
conversions in exactly these
circumstances small-scale rural tourism
through conversion goes hand-in-hand
with building regeneration rural economy
and green tourism policies it is part of
the council strategic vision to promote
the district as a tourist destination
East Essex is rich in natural history
possesses nationally significant coastal
resources and as beautiful landscapes
the prevalence of ecotourism has never
been more pronounced than in the current
age where the fertility of the planets
is better understood the current
proposes a microcosm of that bigger
picture with people increasingly wanting
a countryside experience for its own
sake there is a historic net on the
supply of overnight accommodation in
this sub region the architecture is
sensitive to the character and history
of the building existing openings are
revised or replicated in similar kind to
the extent that some domestication takes
place this is mostly concentrated with
an internal courtyard the traffic
generated will be a fraction of that
experienced from a reasonable
alternatives say for example an 8 to 10
horse stable or Class B one office or
workshop conversion the existence of
barn owls and the potential for bats is
seen as a positive asset for the sites
and the mitigation provisions within the
building design and landscape strategy
seek only to enhance and promotes the
ecological provenance of the site's
flood defense flood monitoring flood
resilience flood response measures are
all mindful of the detailed context of
the sites and have been considered sound
and therefore acceptable by the flood
risk authority and they've confirmed
that in writing in fact all statutory
consultative in support of the
application including no objection from
the Parish Council taking everything
together the proposal takes every box in
relation to sustainable sensitive
development fitting in its context I
note the sincere objections of a small
number of third parties but there are
observations for well below any
threshold that might otherwise lead to a
reason for refusal and in planning terms
this proposal offends nothing and no one
it will encourage visitors into the
district where they will enjoy their
time here in full appreciation of the
local natural environment and whilst
spending money in the local pubs
restaurants and other rural facilities
adding to the vitality and viability of
the local economy it's all levels of
thinking this proposal makes a great use
of a traditional building and is well
within the environmental capacity of the
sides and that really is at the heart of
sustainable development so in doing so
it dovetails door relevant policy a
national local level planning permission
should be granted without delay I'm
grateful for your time thank you
maximum five minutes good evening ladies
and gentlemen my name is Paul masters I
live adjacent to the application site
the offices report before you asserts at
paragraph 15 that this proposal is in
accordance with a number of development
plan policies it says that C free
holiday let's our core strategy policy
compliant they are not it is very
obviously neither hotel nor
bed-and-breakfast but purely residential
bungalows the policies refer to
specifically exclude conversion of rural
buildings to residential dwellings
paragraph 15 is a misrepresentation
repeated in paragraph 16 rendering
conclusion at para forty fundamentally
flawed further the applicant has not
demonstrated any special case or demand
for holiday let dwellings whilst the
local pub attracts local local patronage
it is not reasonable that people would
stay over to visit it as a tourist
attraction the report also suggests that
the building will remain within the
existing footprint this statement is
misleading as it takes no account of
extending the access tract and an and
addition of domestic paraphernalia
garden enclosures car parking etc all of
which will affect openness in dark sky
and coastal protection zone where core
strategy only allows development that
must be located there regarding the
excess gate for the proposed development
this has not been addressed body
officers report but it is inappropriate
being in close proximity to our bedroom
that will cause noise disturbance with
people coming and going at at all times
this will greatly interfere with access
further regarding current access tract
leading to our homes
this is loosely made and needs constant
maintenance and
pare the tract is owned by the applicant
who had a covenant written into our
deeds to have the over line control for
this purpose however this has generally
fallen to us to do only this year we
received letters from the council refuse
department to say access cont be gained
due to overgrowth of the hedging along
the track one of our neighbours tried
several times to contact the applicant
without response and so once again it
singularly fell to us to sort out the
point here is that should the applicant
be successful with planning and approval
there will be increased wear and tear
due to the holiday let business with no
guarantee that one that once in place
the applicant will maintain access any
more than he does now this also begs the
question why should we pay for a
business amenity the development is also
out of NP PF in terms of sustainability
and other impacts such as risks to the
existing bar now in addition this is a
high flood risk area the applicant is
incorrect in stating this area has never
flooded I believe the committee is now
in possession of testimony from a local
resident born and bred in pagglesham
stating that this Flutterfield flooded
in 1953 and in fact was the only part of
the village to do so bearing in mind
both the current National flooding
crisis and the global climate change
crisis we believe this reason alone is
sufficient to refuse the application
aside all other policy contradictions we
have been advised the application is
contrary to a suite of local policies
and that the Planning Court would agree
but even if permission survives that
test members should appreciate that the
likely viability of these holiday lets
is poor so what they will be effectively
doing is paving the way for the
applicant to later achieve to open
market dwellings citing other policy dat
brownfield land as it will become
unsuitable for that use
thank you ladies and gentlemen thank you
for the time and thank you for listening
thank you no one else has indica
nonono's have indicated
thank you I've called this in because
this site has been identified on the
Environment Agency flood mites as flood
zone three for new applications for
residential developments this would
normally require that the abdicate
applicant has demonstrated that the
sequential test has been passed in
addition the exemptions that test which
ensures for example there is a safe
means of access and egress in the event
of an evacuation referring to the MPP F
paragraph 155 onwards this refers to
residential development within flood a
flood zone 3 and a need to keep
development away from these areas this
is reinforced by planning policy
guidance which states that holiday homes
within some three are high-risk this is
understandable as if we consider these
this application we are bringing people
into this part of the district may of
whom will be unaware of flood risk and
flood and its risk moreover not more oh
sorry moreover not beyond the
environmental empowerment agencies flood
risks register where early warning
systems are given and we've had this
around the country already in essence if
we approve this application we are
putting lives at risk not only the
people that are potentially staying at
the proposed development but also the
emergency services rescue emergency
services that were put themselves in a
way of harm to instigate a rescue Thank
You Stanley
Thank You chairman there's two two items
here which I would like to get answered
by the officers one is of its in the
Metropolitan Greenbelt and previously it
was a stable in of horses and what have
you it disturbs me to think that if this
is no longer in use it should be turned
back to metropolitan Greenbelt obviously
the buildings have got to be some
measure of maintenance or reformation of
the premises and this includes that
there isn't substantial flooring if
they're in there that that would have to
be taken out and redone the whole thing
would have to be redone incomplete for a
habitable use the other thing is how
long are these units going to be used
for are they temporary units where they
would have a limited time of occupation
or are they going to be occupied
continuously my other concerns are the
parking area where there is a I believe
there's a pond close by and what has
been done in the way of material wastage
from those vehicles before it gets into
the pond in other words oil and other
like stuff that we've got with with cars
there is no measure on there to say
whether or not there guides are put in a
material filter for the runoff of the
cars the water runoff or anything like
that and that would then indicate they
go straight into the pond which then
will go straight into the stream and
there you are we're going to have the
catastrophe to start with plus effect
this is in the flood zone 3 which has
already been spoken about we are told by
the authority to keep well away from
flood zone 3
as far as way as we could possibly be
not to develop it but to keep away from
it and I find this is literally well
just a terminus a mitigate it by putting
a barrier up or something like that it's
not the right thing to do we don't want
to see occupants not we have seen on the
on the TV recently wading through water
and the higher or further than that and
and this season it's just really you
know it seems to be to be at the wrong
place to do this so if the officers
could tell me what sort of mitigation
there is on on materials from cars that
are being parked and also is it going to
be used 52 weeks of the year or is it
just a small occasion all thank you
we'll gather upon the the comments and
before the officers come back councillor
Reeves Thank You Jay similarly I'd like
the officers to respond to the point
that was made by the neighbor with
reference to in particular the
classification of the land being C one
stroke C 3 the there seems to be a lot
of confusion around this the
classification the classification C one
is hotel and been breakfast which is
clearly not so then the conclusion that
has been written resulted from a
separate specialist that was brought in
by the neighbor is that it actually is C
3 now that is the case then that is
completely contrary to our own policies
and therefore on that point alone should
be refused the other thing is that
there's no report on the need or the
viability of this business being
provided by the applicant
and knowing the area that's there I have
reservations about that purely and
simply because of the access the access
is quite a serious issue there you did
see a photograph on seen on the screen
hopefully where even one of the smallest
refuse lorries that the council has
cannot get close to the actual site
itself that is showing it down the side
of the the neighbor who spoke it's down
the side of his house and it narrows
down to a point where they can't get to
the property that we are in
consideration over I also have serious
considerations as have already been
muted about the floodplain and for that
reason my view is that we should
actually refused this Williams Thank You
chairman councillor Stanley has really
alluded to the points that are right to
be considered is that if this was to be
granted permission could the entire
views be restricted to so many weeks in
a year as these are only holiday less
mr. Shaw
Thank You chairman I've got a point to
bring up and also a question it's been
noted that this is a flood flood Pony
which they accept because looking at
paragraph or page seven point seven
paragraph six the earth 18 they're
saying that the units are going to be on
one level with a small first floor flood
refuge they're already saying they
accept that there could be flooding
there which seems a bit ridiculous also
anybody who knows this area the plow
sale is often bought up at flood forums
with the flooding that's there it's been
going on for three or four years there
I've visited the site recently and that
to wade through about two inches of
water to get down to the road to get
down there
so again there's a problem with with
water the other is our paragraph or page
7 point 8 paragraph 21 where it says
refuse collection is undertaken to the
properties within the chase and it is
considered that this can be extended to
the new holiday let's surely if the
ollidy let's are going to be commercial
so it should be a commercial collection
if it's not who's going to bring the
bins down to the line for collection and
who's going to ensure that the people
who let the properties are going to put
the correct refuge in the bins and not
contaminate the rest of the collection
thank you I have a number of concerns
about this application only this morning
was I actually in the area and the
approach road the highway outside the
business and a resident regularly floods
we're not talking about on the odd
occasion we're talking about regular
flooding and the brains of people across
authoritative ethics since 2015 have
been scratching their heads of how to
resolve that so we're talking about a
real issue not a possibility so with
that very much in mind I feel very
uneasy about the whole issue of flood we
wouldn't be talking about it if we were
proposing a residential building there
so I think we enter into the world of
semantics because people will still be
living there
even though the turnover of the people
living there is frequent that's the
proposal now if we look at it I'd
certainly don't want to do in any way
take away the opportunity for tourism
and for visitors to go to the wonderful
place of pagglesham it is truly
wonderful but it is not a place for
holiday makers people don't go there for
their regular holidays to talk about in
paragraph on 7.3 paragraph three they're
a permeable surface now a permeable
surface is only permeable if water has
got somewhere to go and I would suggest
for most of the time the water has got
nowhere to go because there isn't a
reasonable place for it to go
the turning space the proposal on
outside new residents is inconsiderate
frankly it would cause additional
disturbance to those residents and
really I struggle in terms of what it's
actually going to do there it is a
business operating within an area which
i think is wholly unsuitable for this
type of accommodation thank you chairman
you I will ask officers to come back and
and some of the questions so the the
actual status regarding flooding and a
holiday let greenbelt the timings of the
holiday usage and just the clarification
on the on the class of the use i'll take
them in order so the time limits for
occupation i'm dealt with on page seven
point one four
so conditioner thirteen limits the use
so the individual holiday units hereby
permitted shall be occupied for holiday
purposes only not be occupied by a
person soul or main place of residents
not at any time be occupied by any
individual group of persons for a period
of more than 28 days in any calendar
year in relation to the concern about
the potential oil and other sorts of
particles coming off vehicles on the
post parking area we have a condition
six relating to surface water drainage
that's the condition that you would
usually see a requirement in it for
consideration of any sort of
contamination coming off vehicles onto
surfaces and then going into water
courses or ponds nearby and we could
certainly add that requirement to look
at the need for filtration to avoid
pollutants in that condition six in
relation to flood risk changes of use to
dealt with slightly differently while
they are dealt with differently and to
new buildings or structures a national
policy does not require or does not
prohibit changes of use in flood zone
three this for clarification leading on
we consider that this is not see three
dwellings that are proposed see one we
say that this would this accommodation
would fall into that category and
condition thirteen sort of reached
at that point what we could do just belt
embraces approach is to add into
condition 13 for the voidance of doubt
that this relates to c3 use and not C
I'm sorry c1 type use not c3 there has
been no report on a need for viability
because the our policy does not require
it so the local policy or national
policy doesn't require us to consider
whether there is a need for this type of
use it's the applicants risk as it were
so this is a business proposition a
venture they hope it's successful but
they don't need to demonstrate that
there is a need okay the access for
Laurie is I think we've mentioned that
leading on because we had some more
clarification as to the refuse
collection it's a commercial use that's
proposed so the applicant would be
required to make arrangements of the
collection of the commercial waste from
the site I think that just about deals
with all the questions so members we've
heard from the officers that whether you
liking this or not
it's policy compliant and FD
on seven point eight to one it's got um
says new ex no exes track you show me on
the plane with this new access track
might be oh so I can't see it on the
paperwork so this plan is orientated
northwards that way and so what you've
got is the existing access track here
and off that within the application site
would be the parking area so immediately
the end of the access track and then
sort of path created to the central sort
of courtyard area in the parking is in
around that area there I'm not quite
sure
so it says refuse collection is
undertaken to the properties we've in
the chase and it's considered that it
can be extended to a new holiday less if
required via new access tracks your
signs an access track actually pass
where the axis accesses from the choice
this wouldn't be part of our normal
domestic ways this would be a separate
contract separate arrangements could
come in the back of a transit van I'm
just trying to work out where they're
talking about whether it might be a new
access track so my understanding is this
is the access track that leads from the
sort of main settlement if I go from
East End southwards this track exists
and the refuse collection would be and
the access to the site before you know
holidaymakers would be via this existing
access track with the additional
creation of the sort of parking area and
just to the northern boundary there so
I'm getting out that this bit here
doesn't really mean anything there's new
access track doesn't he's not going to
be a new access track I can see
it's just a little bit from the end of
the existing to the property isn't it
yeah I think in terms of maybe some some
means of turning here but no this tract
exists and it's anticipated that this is
the track that would be used to you sure
you want to come back can you the
National planning policy framework in
conjunction with planning policy
guidance stairs development away from
these areas this development can take
place without risk the lives of the
facility and those are the emergency
services furthermore no details have
been submitted detailing means of escape
from the development indeed the wider
area notwithstanding one singular routes
in and out of this part of the district
I must say I I hear what you say dans
les yeux but the policy that we have is
clearly defined officers and our refer
to offices a moment clearly says this is
acceptable if this was a new build I
could understand your your reason but
it's not would you like to just expand
on that so national policy on flood risk
is very restrictive in flood zone 3
where you are building new buildings
particularly where those buildings are
for residential use
but this application isn't that this
application is seeking to change the use
of an existing building and
in terms of national flood risk policy
is appropriate the use of the building
is for holiday let's and that in
national flood risk policy terms is
different to residential dwellings so
yes
flooding would cause problems and
inconvenience but in national flood risk
policy terms it is not somebody's main
residence that would be damaged by the
proposal it's somebody's holiday that
potentially would be canceled so the
applicant has to take that risk on board
but this application is appropriate in
flood risk terms
I understand all what you've said but
this is military poncing for green belt
and as far as alignment where there are
no special circumstances where this can
kept this can be taken through it is a
stable and it was meant to be a stable
now if it's not going to be used as a
stable like I've said before there are
no special circumstances where this can
be converted for the benefit of the
public and of anybody of the
horse-riding facility or anybody like it
and that's the reason why it is a stable
because of the conditions where it is
put it doesn't matter if it does flood I
know I hear what you say I take it
entirely what you say but this is going
to be presidential and we're that effect
and I if this does not work if this okay
you can't say cancer sterling that this
is going to be residential when clearly
the application in front of us is for a
holiday let you date sure was a holiday
is it no I mean are we not I think I
think what members need to be really
careful about is that what we are doing
here is not making a decision about
whether we like this whether it sounds
appropriate or not we are seeing whether
this application is compliant with our
policy or not
it is compliant with our in our policy
we are bound to approve it if you feel
and can put a case where it is not
compliant with our policy then of course
you may move for refusal after making
your appropriate points what's going to
continue okay I think so mainly say that
under this metropolitan green belt in
our policy there is no special
circumstances for this development okay
so this application is wholly in a
wholly appropriate in green belt terms
in relation to council policy so there
are a number of green belt policies so
gb2 sets out and that's a green belt
policy sets out that the council will
allow forms of rural diversification
including conversion of existing
buildings to Bed & Breakfasts and small
hotels councillor policy DM 13 also
agreeing about policy allows for reuse
of existing buildings in the green belt
of substantial construction which this
is subject to a number of criteria being
met those criteria are taken through in
the officer report but all are met in
this case there is no need for the
applicant to demonstrate very special
circumstances they're only required if
the proposal is inappropriate in the
green belt in the first instance but
this change of use is appropriate
according to the council's green belt
policy okay Cass Reeves
Thank You chair I think one of the
things that's been missed in the
discussion that has come here so has
been point actually brought up by the
neighbor in that their bedroom is right
next to the driveway we have seen the
plan for the car parking there are five
spaces so it's not unreasonable to think
that at some point in time someone who
might come along to use this place here
would turn up in convoy and there'll be
five cars lined up outside the
neighbor's bedroom I think it is
unreasonable of us to actually allow
that to go through there is a very
simple way of actually dealing with this
we're on the approach road there there's
no reason why the gate if we do decide
to
actually give this the okay then there's
no reason why the approach lane there
cannot have the the gate that is at the
top of the gate of the approach their
move to halfway down in consideration of
the noise issue for the neighbors
thank you any other members in decay rap
members we have a officer recommendation
for approval printed on 7.12 a little
bit of information on the addendum but
no fundamental changes are that's Reeves
okay would you like to yeah we'll just
take a bit of advice on on that so on
the gate issue the concern on I
understand this raised by the neighbor
is that their property and I couldn't
get the aerial image up I think we do
have a photo of their property but it's
you can see that it's very close to the
access tract and their window is very
close and so the concern is that people
pulling up to get into this holiday
accommodation would maybe pause in front
of or nearby their property to open the
gate or get access to that gate the
slight concern I have is that this is an
existing track that can be used by
existing traffic I know that's redundant
at the moment and there's no use there
but there's nothing to prevent vehicles
moving up and down this track at present
so we need if we're going to impose a
condition a reason for that condition to
be imposed and so we just need to be
very clear about that I think if we're
going to require them to like I think
we're going down the road of its
requiring them to move the gate further
into the you know so that so you avoid
cars accessing sort of lingering if you
like in front right in front of that
dwelling which could cause some level of
you know inconvenience I think members
um I'm hearing the point and I got I
understand you make the movement for an
amendment to the conditions in a minute
but I'm very wary of working things out
on the hoof often these things do
require some detail and behind them so
in your close on that I think you're
going to make for an additional
condition can I ask you to actually give
within it the scope to officers to fully
investigate this and to work out the
detail and practice
callate of it thank you
reasons being for the amendment would be
twofold one would be emissions directly
against a bedroom window and the other
would be noise nuisance where you see
usage of this facility could have
vehicles approaching at any time of the
day or night and that that is unfold and
that the officers work out a scheme that
will mitigate in terms of the position
of this yeah you know to essentially
position it for the South I guess to
just to avoid cars lingering in front of
the residential five cars to be looking
you second that cancer Stanley right
members would you can I can I just take
a vote on whether that amendment be
accepted to the substantive those in
favor of the amendment okay
that amendment is now added to the
recommendation for approval just wanted
to clarify that that is that the only
amendment we've discussed other plus
what you said you were getting about
some detail and we got okay adding the
detail in relation to condition six yeah
in terms of the particles and though
there was one more that you wanted to
firm up on yes just okay so those
members in favor of the approval with
the small here we go again yeah I've got
congested in terms of the usage I've got
conditions yes let's just go Casa
Williams then we'll just go through it
for clarity cuz I don't want any any
misunderstanding thank you Sheila
I understand that the officer mentioned
changing it back to see one use what was
it that that's what that's what it is
yes it's not changing it that's what
I'm so for clarity yeah the the
conditions as stated say for the
following amendments which would be the
additional condition relating to
officers or a requirement for the gate
to be repositioned to a position to be
agreed with officers but to avoid this
cars accessing the site lingering in
front of the residential properties
nearby and the reason for that condition
relates to emissions being incompatible
with a bedroom window so and the concern
that this actual use could be cars
arriving at any time of day or night
different to the existing use that takes
place an amendment condition six
relating to the need for filtration to
be considered to prevent pollutant
entering the pond water courses yeah
and clarification on condition thirteen
that the use falls within the c1 use
class and not c3 for the avoidance of
doubt those members in favor of the
approval please indicate
those against
thank you that item is approved Kathir
Aves you now stage all right thank you
very much members
that's last month's business dealt with
item 8 land the rear of three 245
Alexandra Road great Wakering
okay
Thank You chair em right okay
Alexandra Road and as we all know the
site lies to the east of addict on the
road which is the main residential
street in quaint way Corinne and the
plan before you kind of shows the layout
of the site if you can see that properly
and I'll refresh them your memories on
what's being proposed and planning
permission is being sought to demolish
number 39 a aleksander Street and the
and it's for the erection of 25
two-story residential dwellings and the
lair of a road car parking and landscape
and land behind Alexander Road the
access insight would be gained from
Alexander road and the site proposed a
mix a 1-1 bedroom property 11 two
bedroom properties and 13 free bedroom
properties of the nine are proposed to
be affordable properties these
affordable units would be sited to
northern and southern ends of the site's
the application was and the application
was deferred from the previous
Development Committee held in October it
was deferred air for the following week
reasons and one being a substation to
construction hours free open spaces and
for angular water and comments em even
on this plan you might get to see the
substation I'm gonna discuss
oh my god against me Oh
sorry right there we go sorry about that
and right okay so the substation if you
can see it does M front plot 25 and and
it is point to it so yes where the
lasers point and that's where the stuff
station is situated sits front so in
front of plot 25 and it's to the rear of
number 39 Alexander road and the
substation would be enclosed by a brick
built structure with a hip roof and the
structures a solid structure and and
comprises louvered panel doors which
would front the highways and a new
access road that's been proposed the
substation has been designed in
accordance with UK power network
guidance this guidance recommends a
fully enclosed brick built enclosure
with a told route can be situated a
minimum of one meter from a habitable
space so and I did have another plan for
even unfortunately hasn't loaded tonight
but that sub station is situated 1.4
meters from the front of plot 25 and I
situated 22 meters from the rear of
number 39 aleksander Road like I said
that is in accordance with the UK power
network guidance and additionally
vegetation an offense would surround the
substation which would soften the
appearance and would help diminish any
noise impact the louvered doors would
point away from neighboring properties
which would also attenuate any noise
emanating from the substation the
mitigation measures proposed are over
and above the requirements is therefore
considered substation proposed is
acceptable
moving on to and construction hours
these have been reduced slightly to 8
a.m. to 7 p.m. Monday to Friday and 8:00
a.m. to 1:00 p.m. on a set yeah on a
Saturday so no work Sunday or bank
holidays the timing proposed in
condition 21 are in accordance with the
Environment Protection Protection Act
1990 and therefore adequate
the open space it was an open space plan
that I was going to show you but again
due to technical issues it's not we're
not lady tonight and and that plan
showed the nearest parks and open spaces
so it showed the nearest park to be
great rate waking recreation ground and
it did also illustrate the football
grounds lachman's nearby but walking
distance from the recreation grounds
about five minutes from this site and so
it is because it's being a course with
council policy and there are open space
nearby for people to go and played well
whatever they wish to do I mean open
spaces and so those faces are considered
adequate moving on to an angler water
and comets were my previously found
response that was received from angling
water favorite discussions have been had
with them the response received was a
standard response and they confirmed a
desktop study has been carried out and
the development mainly and they said
that flooding may occur downstream
however this could not be confirmed and
if this were to be the case or where it
may be this is Baku's angling water
operate under a different legislation to
planning they on they operate under the
water Industrial Act 1991 like I said
this is separate planning and if
planning permission was forthcoming
then angling water would as a next step
engage with the developer and would
undertake further works and such as
hydraulic modeling of the area this
would then ascertain accurate estimates
of water levels and flood extent for
rivers and water courses or sea
notwithstanding that it is because it's
by the buying Namur to that given the
size of development the impact of
development on the surrounding water
network would be instant insignificant
however they do need to carry out
federal works to establish this and
conditions have been recommended to
carry out on-site drainage and surface
water strategies to establish a pumped
rate in any mitigation measures to
prevent flooding outside the site if it
were to occur
so um yeah application is still
recommended for approval subject to
conditions thank you we have two
speakers on this one good evening you
know firstly regarding a substation as a
considerate contractor we've put these
up substation on the drawings however
after talks with our energy architect
there's a great chance there's enough
capacity or reading agreed for us not to
require a substation a lot of developers
don't show the substations because power
network power have the right to do it
under permit dependence to include a
substation later on so we've highlighted
this in case we do need it we've spoken
to the neighbors and we actually have
moved it further away from the fence
which we can show on it's a new drawing
and I believe we're about 1.8 or 2
meters off the fence boundary line now
with a heavier planting scheme they
would sign for our attention you have a
day regarding our section 106 The
Watcher council housing said it was
eight but 35% is actually it's greater
it's nine so I've spoken to Katie and
the section 106 should be nod and not
eight which I think Katie's are well
yeah so there's a being mistake on that
section regarding there was a few
comments the other week regarding
parking where actually with visitors
Bay's we were required to put supplies
6.25 visitors spices including the new
eight in the roadway and the seven we've
got we're technically a hundred percent
better on our visitors car park in
spacing with what is required by us so
the seven in the original straight line
and an additional eight which will be
going into the new ancient straight line
the houses there's also comment that
you'd like to seem slightly bigger sixty
percent of them houses are between 3 and
11 percent
bigger than standards the gardens again
60% of this site are the gardens are
bigger than requirement so we're
actually better than what what set out
by standards I know there's a lot of
concerns regarding sizes and car parking
but unfortunately we don't make the
guidelines we can only follow what is
set out to us so that is a deeper root
problem in then ask that goes up to
Essex County Council so we can only
follow what is set out in front of us
there was also some concerns will upset
me a little bit because I feel like as a
company we've been mistreated regarding
how we've approached this site when we
first bought this site the lady and the
son the lady was quite ill so we didn't
we waited two years she we bought the
property she had money to pay for her
care and she lived in her house the new
two years until she passed away so we
didn't touch anything regarding the
clearance I took our lady who does our
health and safety from innumerous my
numerous or my big businesses the
greenhouses were unsafe they were timber
construction and they were falling apart
with broken glass which we've got
photographic evidence we've got reports
from our health and safety lady advising
us after speaking to the headmistress of
the school children climb underneath the
fence to reclaim their bowls now from a
father
what would you any of you do if one of
your children had gone on set saw and
been injured by planning broken
greenhouses so we took it upon ourselves
to clear it there's also comments that
we had no respect for wildlife I've got
letters from our solicitors which state
we didn't do any clearance in that land
until October once the burden season had
finished we've also heard that the
Forestry Commission come down saying
that we was neighbors of five tops who
were clearing land we're doing this were
doing that no enforcement was brought
against us because we we haven't removed
any trees we've cleared bramble bushes
and I feel a bit without sounding tic
for tack here I've actually had contact
the place for fly-tipping
where people think it is acceptable to
throw their rubbish over the back of
their garden to let other people clear
photographs place evidence place and it
was only me who decided
prostitute pardon so these people also
seven after sixteen properties have got
gates going onto someone else's property
is that is that acceptable I know some
of you feel strongly about this and I
know there's a big issue regarding
construction about parking but
everything is demonstrated would be
demonstrating our concentrating
construction method statement we talked
about parking has anyone had problems
down fairly lying with construction
people parking in the rows anywhere
construction issues down water flying
with the construction no because
everything is put in place to prevent
that I've got no desire to upset anyone
or heaven that's not my engulf but I
think some of this has been fairly
untreated on some of these and you just
keep deferring it and deferring it I'd
rather tonight it's even refused or
passed and then I can go forward with
what I need to do next I apologize if I
come across rude or blunt that is not my
intention at all so nothing thank you
thank you
[Music]
that's already on as a preamble
Alexander rode until world war two was a
contract to the fields down the bottom
where there's a few houses down the
field him but the mainland Wellings were
at the top end near the high street
there's small mainly bungalows type
dwellings some had side paths for pony
and tracks and things like that and some
were built in the late 19th century very
in World War two it was found essential
to build an ack-ack gun site in the
fields at the bottom in the road to
build it and service it with stores and
ammunition a concrete slab road was laid
directly on the ground it does not have
to be fancy or tape much care and
construction because what few cars there
were at that time were either on blocks
for the duration unless they were
engaged in the essential war work and
had an allocation of petrol couponers at
the end of the war at some time you know
the council at some level or possibly
the army works organisation tarmacked
over the slabs I do not know when the
service is series water gas electricity
will put you there was still few Cal now
for the war and lorries were lousy small
by today's standards they used to be 98
houses in the road but this had more
than trebled since the back at gun site
was developed a photograph it shows the
full width of 39 over the boundary
pillars and walls the broken the war on
the left by the two wheelie bins the far
pillar we fought at which 41 was eleven
point five eight metres 38 feet
photo - which should be the road outside
- I know yeah so the front of 39a the
floating slab cracks and the extensive
damage to the footpath and drop curb
area immediately opposite number 39 a so
if cars can do this what will be the
effect of heavy lorries making sharp
90-degree turn from this road
this is six point oh nine meters widest
road or 20 feet curb to curb the
services these houses may well also be
damaged especially the sewage system
photo 3 that's the service insulin a
view of the same yeah a view of the same
shot towards a high street and showing
the break up and broken lower curbs
going near the top left photo for just
sewing a bit of subsidence at the curb a
little further on cracking along a
center of the road and a slab plat crack
with the patch 405
anyway I should show general radiating
crack damage the manholes mr. one yeah
you can see all the cracks radiating out
of that and into the other manhole
further up the next photograph showed
parking either side of thirty-nine a
which was help in further loss of
parking if the powers are flared and
double yellow lines are pointing to give
line-of-sight you can see there the
vehicles back to either side photograph
seven which ranks the last one this is a
view from the bottleneck area towards
the High Street showing a car coming
down the road
you're the best wood in the world it
says in the it's and one of these
reports that its people park on the
pavement to facilitate dual lane traffic
when you're doing it to go get one car
at a time down there unless there's a
happens to be of agency in the parking
spaces this this photograph was taken at
3:00 p.m. last Tuesday afternoon and as
it can be seen a single lane traffic
Road evenings and weekends this is much
more apparent the rule of the road is
that traffic is already committed coming
from the high street going to have an
firm unless traffic is already committed
coming from the high street those going
towards the high street have preference
there is much headlight flashing to
achieve this everyone except possibly
visitors are well aware of the
difficulties angkor for eight fully
because this is a cold a second to which
another quarter sack is about rebuilt so
everyone is pretty courteous at present
it's a cul-de-sac but when the act that
gun site was developed a curved embryo
road we put in I'm afraid that's your
time
thank you just reminder there's a tiny
little bit on the addendum for this one
absolute person Thank You chairman just
one thing
committee members I think he's good
proper and right for this committee
scrutinizes every single development
item that comes before you so that we
make sure that it is fit for purpose
whether that is once or twice or three
times okay
Alexandra Road first of all I would like
to say it's good to see that a lot of
the previous concerns have been
addressed
however this development whether we like
it or not will have a detrimental impact
on residents parking even though the
developer has confirmed that the access
road will be available for residents of
Alexandra Road to use Asics highways in
their infinite wisdom have deemed that
this road Alexandra Road is suitable
even though a separate department from
Essex County Council had referred to a
different Alexander Road in the first
application that came forward to us so
I'll be honest I have more faith in West
Ham United winning the Premiership then
I have in Essex highways decision-making
so again
in fact we are coupled by Essex highways
I wonder if we can charge it six
highways when our bin lorries can't get
into the development coupler points
could I refer to the committee to page
eight point seven regarding condition 21
I believe that the previous meeting the
hours were requested to be restricted
less than Charon here I would hope the
committee would possibly consider
reducing operating hours to 8 a.m. to 6
p.m. weekdays and no weekend works
as developer said there is a very close
proximity proximity to the residential
amenities of the neighboring properties
this reduction would allow our residents
some rest buy some peace in their
gardens I believe this would mirror
conditions on a nearby site the Taylor
Wimpey site that they that officers
could perhaps look at that and confirm
if they're restricted at weekends
mentioning the nearby site there is also
a dampening down condition due to the
excessive dust the site throws up their
dust that has affected some local
residents with respiratory issues I
wonder if a similar condition could be
considered here regarding the remaining
conditions
I believe officers and the committee
members have been thorough I am mindful
that should this committee approve this
development I know that officers will
ensure that the developer Rd is to each
and every condition that is included I
don't think there's anything else I've
got to add to this thank you very much
chairman Thank You members okay
it's up to members just to remind
members we we obviously have seen this
application before and we have at our
previous meetings asked for all of the
concerns to be investigated and they've
come back so I do personally believe
that you are equipped with all the
necessary information to make a proper
decision tonight can't slow FD
Thank You chairman yeah I agree with
most what customers Pearson said looking
at the hours but I can do work I agree
that it should be maybe eight or six
weekends people going to work Saturdays
but with the amount of traffic that
happens on Saturdays and Sundays
actually in that road maybe we could put
a restriction on big deliveries coming
through on a Saturday because I think
that will cause damage to vehicles along
the road is that possible to do as a
condition councillor Stanley Thank You
chairman I hear what the officer says
about the flooding situation as if it
requires it they will look at the
possibility Arthur that's sort of really
put in the office behind the car instead
of in front of the car system works
though yeah I do be a nice day yes
so with a lot of sites as I was going to
mention that we do actually ask for
documentation on on run offs and what
have you and again I put it I would ask
the officer if some mitigation could be
put in for the runoff off that site from
all the properties I daresay that they
will comply with parking development how
you construct your parking bases and
whatever you but the Randolph I would
like to see some sort of mitigation to I
don't know if there's a veil ability to
put upon somewhere for the runoff so
that this can be as in the land drainage
act you are not allowed to deposit water
which is not naturally intended for it
to be as that was a site that was not
developed but just that greeneires is in
it was able to the water was able to
percolate through the soil the lamed act
says that you are not allowed to put
water where or to
but what we call sin or anything like
that where it is not naturally intended
so I would like to know what mitigation
that the officers can put to that to to
make this a viable site I have to tell
men say that the site it looks to be
very good there are just a little tweaks
here and there that needs to be done and
I'm sure that the officers will have
this in mind thank you don't comment on
the and yes the construction hours have
been recommended between 8 and 7 Monday
to Friday and 8 and 1 on a Saturday and
these are like I said before in line
with the Environmental Protection Act
and these standard conditions that are
imposed on on developments across the
district
I wouldn't necessarily suggest reducing
those hours um I mean I know it's only
one hour in the daytime to be Monday
Friday but you know these are standard
hours and you know reducing these hours
microphone would be your prayer along in
the development longer the construction
of ear so I would suggest sticking with
the 8 to 6 and 8 to 7 condition as
recommended and with regards to delivery
vehicles that was mentioned on a
Saturday there is a condition and
recommended for construction method
statement so that could be dealt with
via that I mean we've discussions with
the applicant and and with regards to
such stuff there is condition for which
does refer to surface water drainage
scheme and just refer to a discharge
rates of water and this will also have
to States or appropriate mitigations
within the site but there isn't any
scope for a pond to be situated on site
however I think maybe an attenuation
tanks might be a way forward and an
appropriate means to deal with the this
surface water and drainage on the site
and
yeah Thank You counselor wooden German
just a question have we talked about how
they're gonna do with dust but
conversely what about we're washing
facilities because I note on
developments generally there's this all
seems to be a bit lacks and I don't
expect there to be a robust cleaning
regime on residential roads and actually
we're washing before the the mud
actually gets on the road yeah I
completely agree but again this will be
dealt with by the constructive method
statement and I'd say there has been a
condition that's been recommended that
the applicant does need to submit a
construction myth a statement to be
discharged by the council is that we
don't live by that Thank You chairman
could I
is there a condition on on the wall to
retain the attenuation tank is that is
there a condition that we that the
officers are going to put in or do I
need to propose that well the first
paragraph of condition for where the
officers have got to be satisfied that
the surface water drainage scheme is
agreed and in place before it happens so
it wouldn't be appropriate for us to say
tank pond or or whatever it's what's
appropriate for the site so members we
have the recommendation
starting on 8.1 going through in quite a
lot of detail on through 28.7 and no
members have heard that the particular
concerns regarding when washing and dust
will be worked out in advance with
officers via the method statement
condition so can I please ask those
members in favor of approve one please
indicate
thank you
those against that item is approved
thank you
thank you item 9 removal of condition 3
on a planning application yeah that's
fine no just our location members this
application site is to the northern
boundary of the Brook Road industrial
estates the site is a frontage onto
cidar road here and borders a number of
residential the rear boundary of a
number of residential properties on
woodlands Avenue there's a track that
runs between the boundary and the rear
garden boundaries to these properties
here the application relates to the
single story building on the site that
is shown here which was granted planning
permission for use as a gym in 2017 but
can take you to the photos
yes yes yes
sorry
so these photographs if you can just
scroll through them show the the
building existing on the site which has
been converted to a gym if you keep
going down so that's them just the
general vicinity of the area so that's
the unit opposite on Brook Road
Industrial Estate and then this is
internally if you can just pause there
so there's one so there's a door here
and that's on the elevation away from
the residential properties to the north
if you can keep scrolling down so this
shows the parking available to the site
so this is the side elevation that then
faces that access tract with the rear
garden boundaries to the properties and
woodlands Avenue and to the north that's
the site frontage again you can see the
parking so the previous photograph
extended to this side here and then
there's parking to the site frontage and
then against Katy and then that's just a
wider view well we'll leave those photos
there if I can then take you to the more
recent photographs
yeah and in just scroll down to the next
one and again so this is the access
track a clearer view of it that
separates so this is the site boundary
here and this is the rearguard and
boundary with some substantial trees to
that from that site and if you can go
down again this just then shows the end
of the turning head so this is along the
northern boundary in the site's just off
the photo here and there's a an access
public right-of-way that runs through to
those properties then that go onto
woodlands Avenue so the consent was
granted back in 2017 for use of the
building as a gym subject to a number of
planning conditions and it's condition
three that this application seeks to
vary this condition restricts the use of
the gym to a maximum of ten people at
any one time and the reason for the
imposition of this condition related to
parking and residential amenity the
applicant has stated that this is an
overly restrictive condition on their
business and therefore seek the removal
or variation of this condition members
might recall that this application was
heard at the development committee in
December last year and the discussion at
the committee focused on the need to
ensure that any expanded use of the gym
would not cause harm to residential
amenity of the nearby dwellings on
woodlands Avenue members deferred the
item to allow officers further time to
consider issues relating to the possible
possible limb requirement for monitoring
equipment for sound appropriate sound
levels for music within the building air
conditioning equipment and soundproofing
of the building so since that committee
meeting officers have met with
environmental health officers and
planning enforcement officers to discuss
the proposal and the recommendation
remains one - a very conditioned three
to allow you to the gym up for up to 30
people at any one time this revised
restriction would allow the business to
develop and it's considered that this
level of use would not give rise to harm
to residential amenity we take those the
four reasons why it was deferred in turn
so the monitoring equipment for sound in
discussion with environmental health
officers it's considered that it's not
necessary to undertake any further
monitoring for noise
levels you can go back to the location
plan please monitoring for noise has
already taken place in one of the
residential properties bordering the
site and that was in response to a
complaint received prior to this
application being heard in their 2018
development committee that was a year
ago
so noise equipment has already been
installed in one of the residential
properties to the north that the result
of that was that there was no noise
nuisance
it found within that property and rising
from the proposed that from the use of
the building as a gym when equipment for
noise monitoring is installed this is
for the purpose of determining whether a
noise nuisance is occurring and it would
be no benefit to monitor noise levels at
the site boundary because whether a
noise nuisance was established here is
neither here nor there essentially
because what we're talking about is what
is the level of noise within the
residential properties nearby and that
monitoring has already been done a year
has passed and we've had no further
noise complaints received from any
neighboring properties in more than sava
new appropriate levels for music within
the building was the other concern again
it's not considered necessary to impose
a specific level at which music could be
played within the building or not
exceeded because condition 5 already
requires that music cannot be played
when windows and doors are open the if
you'll remember seeing that photograph
that the door they open is also to this
southern elevation so the existing
conditions would remain in place and
these are considered to be sufficient
safeguard to residential amenity with
regard to air conditioning a summer has
now passed and no noise complaints have
been received by the council relating to
this gym use the conditions which
require the windows and doors to be shot
when music is playing would remain in
place and there's no indication that
this condition has been breached in the
last year if the applicant did find that
the gym environment became too warm in
the summer months either the music would
have to be switched off if the windows
and doors were open or the applicant
would have to apply to seek to install
conditioning equipment but it's not
appropriate for us to insist on the
provision of air conditioning equipment
at this stage and soundproofing so again
it's not considered necessary to require
soundproofing given the existing
conditions we haven't had any additional
complaints and the conditions that are
would remain in place are considered to
be an adequate safeguard it's therefore
recommended that condition 3 be varied
to allow for the use of the gym for up
to 30 people at any one time
with all the remaining conditions as
originally worded thank you
five minutes so
thank you just to clarify those photos
were taken over a year ago and they
would literally just show in the two
extension rooms that wasn't done in the
rebuilder has caused places but the fire
burn out the building before we moved in
and then they rebuilt it but those two
rooms weren't done nor was there if you
see all their plants and stuff like that
that was an area that could be developed
for more parking so I would just like to
adjust a few of the issues that came up
when applying for the original planning
applications led to a cap to be placed
on the amount of people who could drain
at once with regards to the parking we
have cleared a newly time at the entire
forecourt allowing us to hold up the 15
cars at once we also have a side area
where me and the staff park that was it
can hold up to four or five cars down
the side plus we have another rear area
at the back which is still not developed
which we could turn into another car
park if we needed and we could also put
another gate on the on the back of that
so that's giving us between 20 and 25
spaces lots of our members are couples
so they're having one car between them
some like the bikes some walk at the
class of 10 sometimes we only only have
about five cars in the car park there
also many places down the road to park
and only even in a weekends and the
whole industrial start is closed so all
of those spaces are free we also have
permission from the roofing company
across the road when as soon as they're
closed we're allowed to use their car
parking spaces as well which is another
10 spaces so we have plenty of parking
and it never has been and never will be
an issue
we forgot to the sound and this building
is the newest one on the estate it was
rebuilt at a higher standard three years
ago after a fire it has a thick
insulated roof which acts as a huge
sound barrier and it's also gets a
building warm in the winter and cooler
in the summer hence the reason what we
haven't yet got a heating or gate
conditioning because we don't need it
since occupying this building I spent
thousands of pounds and lots of
resources making it making it as quiet
as possible I've insulated in
soundproofing the two adjacent small
rooms so on there that now they're
completely done which weren't done in a
rebuild I've closed off and boarded up
an insulated one-day-old roller shutter
entities that
that used to face the residential side
we've got rid of all the original
speaker system and now we we have like a
little like a sound bar that you'd get
in your front room and we've replaced
all of our weights with rubber weights
to reduce the noise every we've put
rubber flooring throughout the whole gym
from what I'm wearing off it's been very
successful
and although we may have had a few
complains at the start we haven't had
any in over a year our gym is not like a
normal gym we took some pictures of
actually inside it and it's a very big
space we don't have any machines like
weight weight lifting machines or
bodybuilders at the gym it's just normal
people or I want to get fitter and
become healthier we try and put people
in small group sessions and teach them
everything they need to know about
exercise and nutrition our training
consists of functional movements which
basically means movements that carry
over into real life we get people run in
jumping squatting climbing ropes lifting
heavy objects and carrying weights we
have a lot of police officers paramedics
nurses and firefighters you're trained
of us because question is becoming a
staple program for first responders and
the military we also have members as old
as simply two in our program we have
built a strong community of a hundred
members and with the cap of only ten
people per session
there's ample as possible to grow the
business anymore we have employed to
full-time coaches and just taken our
first apprentice which we'd love to
continue to continue to grow and be able
to provide a more career opportunities
in the future the building we have is
very big it could easily hold 40 to 50
people but because there's a type of
service that we provide we don't want a
session to be anywhere near that big we
have our main floor area bathrooms
reception room and two other rooms
coming off the main building because of
its size we don't qualify for any small
business rate relief at all so having a
cap of ten people at once makes it
impossible for us to grow and makes it
very hard financially it's a shame
because it feels like we're just
scratching the surface of the impact we
can make a silikal area we would never
want more than twenty people in your
class at once even if you had permission
the whole point of cost is how small
intimate classes for example are never
increased a week weekday morning
sessions to more than 16 people because
the majority will Qui showers and go to
work and we don't have facilities to
accommodate us
however on a Saturday morning most cut
most classes say under Saturday morning
what causes our more popular it'd be
nice to have it up to about 20 people
because everyone what sort of training
around 10:00 a.m. we also have the Tuck
the other two rooms which would provide
good career opportunities for two other
personal trainers or Mays maybe a
physiotherapist
so to summarize a cap a cap of 25 to 30
people would be extremely beneficial it
would help us grow as a business and
provide more job opportunities to people
in the future but as mentioned it would
be very rare for us to hit those numbers
Thank You members does anyone need to
say anything about this one family Thank
You Jaime just double check counselor
mail comes to Steptoe okay
thank you Jim what it's advantageous to
increase the membership and I don't see
any reason why this business can't do
that my thoughts are that using other
premises which do not belong to that
premises the gym for parking could be
contravened it later on boy whoever
they're bothering the parking space is
from I do understand that the car some
cars are used with four people in or two
people that sort of thing but to
increase you know can I just stop you
there this is about varying condition
three and car parking isn't part of that
condition of three was imposed for two
reasons so partly it was to do with the
amount of parking and partly it was to
do with the residential amenity but the
item was deferred in relation to the
residential amenity issues okay that's
correct not deferred on the car parking
thank you so yeah I'll go back to what
was I
I see no reason why it cannot be
increased as the applicant would like it
increased to 20 spaces I see no reason
for that
and I fully understand he has got
parking spaces for their additional ten
but to have an additional any more than
that could lead to a problem later
during the existence of the business so
I would have hold his application but on
the basis of condition of only ten more
ten more
thank you chairman with the information
that we've just received I can see no
reason to we told this and I propose
that we accept this proposal thank you
very much thank you I second that they
can also catch late the pose on this -
Eve getting on with his neighbor's which
is in their pool which is really good
for for me I think the the fact that
there have been no there's no no further
contact with the council over the last
12 months I think so it says that what
is requested is that's doing with Acer
members those favor those members in
favor of the recommendation as stated on
on 9.1 SH the removal of condition three
please indicate
those against okay that item is approved
lunch abstain okay thank you
next is item 10 preferred from the
weekly list land opposite one to 10
Disraeli Road Rayleigh again a little
bit of information on the addendum for
that one it's got this one Thank You
chairman write the application site is
situated on the northern side of
Disraeli Road as you can see in that
plan for you and the site is it rating
the green bell and at the moment is
vacant from development and free horses
graze this piece of land
my information is being sought to write
stable block comprising three individual
stables and laying out of hard standing
the stables has been applied for as the
applicant is planning permission to
convert the existing stables at the rear
of number 10 Disraeli rode into a
residential dwelling the MPP F allows or
National Planning policy framework
allows for the provision of appropriate
facilities for outdoor recreation as
long as the facilities preserve the
openness of the green Bell stables are
considered as outdoor recreation and
considered to be appropriate development
the Greenbelt provided does not conflict
with the openness this is we reiterated
in the preamble for policy DM 15 of the
development management plan which
confirms proposes should seek to
minimize the impact of proposed
developments on the openness to the
Greenbelt and character the countryside
by ensuring that any new buildings are
of a modest and design and scale which
is appropriate and the minimum size
isn't necessary for the intended purpose
it's considered that the stable is a
single single-story nature and modest
and has the appearance of a stable
building it's important to ensure that
the welfare welfare of horses through
the provision of a question facilities
is balanced against the potential impact
on the openness of the Greenbelt and
character of the countryside
according to the British horse the whole
society nought point for a hectare of
land is required per halls or pony to
graze the areas of land required he
stated in policy DM 15 is considered
that sufficient evidence has been
provided by the applicant to prove that
there is an agreement with other land
owners in the nearby vicinity to to
maintain and use the land for grading of
horses the land at the application site
and the land provide by others equate to
1.2 hectares of land
this is considered adequate amount of
land said the horses in turn stables
proposed would not have a tangible
impact upon the openness of the
Greenbelt and satisfy the MPP F and
policy DM 15 I must report early to the
committee that addition in addition to
safeguard land
and any impact from the green bell the
applicant has agreed to enter into
section 106 legal agreements the six
this section 106 will ensure that the
stable building should be removed
it's a grazing land then becomes
unavailable on this basis the
application has been recommended for
approval thank you thank you
we have speaker on this one
good evening mr. chairman good evening
everybody
um while still first sight this
application may seem reasonable sorry I
should say I'm here to represent
neighbors two three five six seven eight
of disraeli Road and whilst on first
sight this application may seem
reasonable we wish to highlight some
facts that we feel are very relevant and
should be considered as evidence as to
why this application should not be
granted if I refer you to your agenda
you will be able to see that there is a
long history of a previous planning
applications at this site for
residential dwellings ranging from nine
detached houses to two detached
properties so as you can see it is very
clear that a precedent has been set by
the applicant showing the true
intentions are to build residential
properties on this land because this has
not been possible by applying to build a
stable block this will then give
leverage to later convert it into a
residential dwelling and we feel that
this is a backdoor way and an abuse of
the planning system as far as we are
aware there are no restrictions within
the planning policy to prevent this from
happening at a future date which is why
we feel this has to be stopped from the
outset and for this reason be viewed as
a material consideration in respect of
the area of land we do not believe it
meets the minimum amount of nought point
4 hectares per horse as mentioned from
the British or standard society even
after taking into consideration past
returner and additional fade despite the
letters from the adjoining land owners
claiming the applicant has use of their
land the applicant still does not have
legal control over these areas and
therefore this agreement can change at
any given moment the applicant statement
that a smaller area may be adequate
where a horse is principally housed and
grazing areas are used only for
occasional turnout is not supported as
these horses will be permanently turned
out onto the grazing area
we understand that the planning officers
recommended a conditional requirement be
applied for a legal agreement to be put
in place to ensure the additional
grazing land be available in perpetuity
however we feel that this is not a
solution because the adjoining
landowners also wish to develop and
build on their land as per those
previous planning applications and all
this will do is once they wish to apply
for planning permission again which they
will they will end the contract and
apply for the condition to be removed so
we are suggesting a more reasonable
condition would be that the stables
remain as searched in perpetuity because
if the stables are genuine then there
should be no issue in imposing such a
condition we would also argue that this
stable block does harm the openness of
the greenbelt
there actually are no other buildings in
this open area and the report stated
that there are stables in the adjoining
land but that is incorrect there is a
lean-to shack and not stables therefore
we do not feel that this is a fair
assessment of the out of the space and
it is very clearly open Greenbelt
regarding the decision letter on point
13 I would quote where it says it is
considered that it would have a moderate
harmful impacts on the openness of the
Greenbelt well we would argue that if
the development causes a moderate
impacts on the openness of the Greenbelt
even if limited and it does not preserve
the openness of the Greenbelt and
therefore it has to be in appropriate
development if moderate impacts was
permitted the National Planning policy
framework would say that and I would
refer to the case our boot versus
Elmbridge Borough Council also
concerning highway safety the previous
rejected decision for this stated that
the the site would not be within a
suitable distance wasn't related to an
existing bride away or by way and would
conflict with highway safety
for this application now this is
currently being deemed no longer an
issue but I would ask why are no more
evidence because nothing has changed
since the original decision and actually
we would say that there is now over more
of a dangerous Highway Safety because
you are accepting that the applicant
will be using the highway regularly to
move the horses up and down often down
the road to the adjoining areas of land
so we would also ask you to consider the
consistency principle here as per the
case in Davidson versus Elmbridge
Borough Council okay made I contacted
planning about calling this Eden because
as you can see presentation we just had
but there is an ongoing since 1999
succession of flight attempted planning
applications to get past to build
residential dwellings on this piece of
Greenbelt added to that there was
reference made to planning application
19 double O 4 1 4 it's virtually
identical to 734 except it was rejected
but to get it past all the applicant had
to do is get a letter from somebody says
these horses can wander into the land
next door and I would order feed to be
delivered to the to the stables there is
an uneasy feeling with the residents are
spoken to that really this ultimately is
to lead to
a planning application in the future on
a footprint of something so I know it's
Greenbelt and they shouldn't be doing it
but when we look at this and added to
that I'll say where we are in Essex
planting a million trees and all the
rest of it what are we doing with
concreting over a piece of Greenbelt so
I'm just appeal to the members if that
they reject this application but if they
feel that they're going to vote for it
is it possible they could consider a
condition that it should remain as a
stables as asked by Fay Vincent and not
ever be converted to residential
properties otherwise we're just going to
get creeping sprawl that is going to
build go into this beautiful piece of
Greenbelt that is actually surrounding
Raley thank you Thank You chairman just
to add ask the committee just to clarify
the point the officers mentioned about
the 106 agreement with the possibility
of removing it once it's no longer
required or circumstances change as to
whether it is a what they consider a
terrible temporary mobile building
sometimes stables are considered as such
and all it has is a concrete slab that
can be easily removed and not footings
put into the ground okay that's a
stanley he also referred this item yes
I'd like to record oh don't be Kukui
okay yes Thank You chairman with the is
very well known in the hospitality that
two horses really do have to go together
at all times because of their nature
they're not a a single entity they don't
stroll around on their own they like
company it keeps them calm and
what-have-you and this is from the host
Federation their selves on the basis
that the
lanes that may be used later or anytime
there's only so much grazing you could
do on a pass or lane and even for two
horses they were so wipeout filled in in
a matter of weeks
especially at winter time when there is
really no grazing format always just
churns it up into mud and we've seen
that happening whole bridge road some
some time before this and on this basis
alone I cannot support this application
on the basis for the amount of land
available for those horses thank you
yeah Reeves thank you
collar points following on from the
neighbors presentation just the one of
the things that really concerns me about
this is okay they have put in with the
application that they have permission
from neighboring fields to use these
fear words in line with the concerns of
the neighbors if these are with that
permission is withdrawn which can be
withdrawn I am guessing at a moment's
notice how we're going to place this
this is a condition of allowing this
this and it seems very very loose there
is nothing no legal contract that we've
been presented with for the the actual
use of this land for as long as the
stables are in there and I just think
that this is just an issue that is
looking to come back and and bite us at
some point it's on second thing is just
a point to make is that this is the
second application we've heard tonight
where we've had completely conflicting
reports from Essex highways again and
this is becoming a regular feature of
reports that are coming to us and I
think that you know this we should make
a point to our highways that this is now
becoming an issue and that we would like
to see some more consistency in the
reports that they actually present
present to us for these reports society
thank you
okay would you like to come back
particularly on the detail of the si 160
yeah
so I think we want to be clear that the
section 106 we are requiring the
developer to enter into would be worded
such that the building should be used as
a stable block and for no other purpose
unless the land in its entirety was no
longer available in which case the
building would be removed in its
entirety including footings of whatever
they might be so in that respect I don't
think there's any need for any other
condition relating to the use to be
solely as a stable because the section
106 requires that it wouldn't stop no
section 106 or condition imposed on the
consent would stop the applicants
ability to come back at a later date
where the proposals change the use of
that building but the condition
essential there's the section 106 sorry
essentially mitigates that possibility
because it requires that it's just a
stable block in perpetuity unless the
lands not there what the applicant could
do is come back and apply to vary the
106 and we can't stop them applying to
do that but in that case the application
for the varied 106 or the removal of the
106 ie they want to keep the building
but the land is no longer all available
would be assessed in relation to our
counts of policy at the time so as it
stands today we would be refusing the
application to remove the 106 because
there wouldn't be sufficient land and it
would be an appropriate development in
the green belt in terms of policing the
106 a 106 is much stronger than a
condition on a planning consent because
it's a legal agreement that the
applicant is entering into so whilst a
planning condition potentially has the
ability to be breached for ten year
period in which case the applicant can
apply for a lawful development
certificate to say that that's been
breached for 10 years and there is no
longer applicable okay that doesn't
apply to a section 106 legal agreement
so that is a
stronger means of ensuring that this
staple brought remains as a staple block
in perpetuity and is removed if that
land is no longer available but yes it
does require neighbors are supposed to
be vigilant people walking about to be
bid vigilant and any concerns they might
have to be reported to our planning
enforcement team and then they can
enforce the terms of that 106 but the
106 remains in place
regardless of how long it's been
breached so it could be breached for a
while it doesn't then follow that that
would become lawful through passage of
time so it is a much stronger tool and I
think that's probably covered everything
in relation to that any other members
want to speak before I go back to
council age to finish off explanation
okay if I summarize to say that this
can't be used as a Trojan horse to build
inappropriate residential in in the
Green Bay it's still green belt
we've got stable potentially built in
there but that doesn't actually then
follow that you can do something else
about it doesn't stop the applicants
ability to put in an application at a
later date seek to vary that section 106
but that application would again be
considered in relation to policy and as
it stands at the moment the way the
council policy is that would be resisted
thank you the explanation is pre-clear
but the one thing that would be
concerning to me is that there doesn't
seem to be any reference to who these
landowners are who have the adjacent
fields can that be incorporated in the
agreement
I don't think it needs to be because the
section 106 is a legal agreement that
would be signed by the applicant for
this application and it will identify
the specific areas of land that the
applicant has identified and those areas
of land could change hands and they
could still be available to the
applicant for grazing because they might
have a you know the same agreement with
the new landowner so the ownership of
those other areas doesn't matter so much
as to whether they're available or not
for the grazing of horses in relation to
this site so it's really the
identification of the areas that matters
rather than the ownership and that will
be a plan appended to the 106 that
identifies those areas of lund
thank you chairman and thank you for for
the clarity on the 106 just as a
follow-up would we be relying on
residents who inform us if this land was
no longer available to the applicant or
do we have measures in place to find out
ourselves yes so as with any condition
really I suppose what we don't do is you
know have the ability to go and monitor
every condition and whether there's been
compliance with it but a 106 is
reiterated it's different to a condition
because it's a legal agreement so even
if it's breached its so say that land
isn't available and they're sort of
carrying on regardless it would be very
obvious to residents in the street if it
weren't used for stabling anymore so I'm
sure we'd get a call in relation to that
it might be less obvious that the other
land weren't available but at the point
where I guess this development becomes a
potential development becomes a problem
as in they want to you know change the
use it would be very obvious when
looking back at the history that a
section 106 applies to this site that
requires the demolition of the building
when the stable when the land is no
longer available so at that point it
would highlight to us so the stable use
is the only use that's going to happen
really and if another use sort of arises
I'm sure residents would
you know bring it to our attention just
follow up on that thank you for that
clarification I'm I'm concerned about
the welfare of the animals really there
doesn't seem to be a way that we know
that they have the amount of land that
the British horse-riding Association and
says they should have available to them
I am concerned by that I wanted to know
Syd thank you finally come back one more
time councillor Stanley and then well
Thank You chairman with the with the
stables of the power base that has that
been taken into the same the size of the
plot or is that been taken off the size
of the plot to give us a full amount of
land that's available
yeah the hard standing that's proposed
has been taken into consideration size
of the plot
it hasn't been it hasn't been taken off
no well the huh standing measures nine
point two deep by free meters wide so
that we 27 square meters is it very
small parcel yeah yeah I think I think
members we've got we've got sufficient
information had sufficient debate on
which to make a decision so there is a
motion move a motion for approval 10.1
11 with the addition of the detail the
comprehensive detail that we've had
explained to us with regard to the
section 106 those members in favor of
the approval please indicate
okay those against okay mister up
staying two abstentions that item is
improved members we've got one item to
go it's quarter to ten you happy to
extend standing orders to code to
dealing with just this final item okay
sorry chairman my numb Cooney interest
is in this item not in item just gonna
wait two minutes very quickly if anyone
wants it goes to low because we're
extended beyond turn potentially this is
this is the problem
unfortunately and Craig Daniel there's
Nick Craig on you to go Chris
he's there right
final item tonight then 22 main road
Hockley the site is part of hockey town
center the site is occupied by a large
building towards the front of the site
here and also has buildings to the rear
the main building was previously in use
an electrical store at ground floor with
offices above if you can take you to the
approved layout please the site benefits
from planning permission for conversion
to residential flats above a ground
floor reach retail unit this was granted
planning permission on appeal in 2014
the approved scheme here shows the
layout of the site so this is the
frontage onto Main Road it shows an
amenity space to the front this is the
main building and then there's a car
parking area sort of centrally
positioned and a car parking area
adjacent to the boundary and to the
north the approval also allowed for
alteration extension conversion of the
existing buildings to the rear to
provide three residential units if I can
take you to the approved elevation
please just to give you a flavor this is
the approved front elevation from the
2004 scheme and the sorry the proposed
scheme is very similar to this so the
addition the scheme in 2014 allowed for
an additional floor so you have the
ground floor here with a residential
flat and the retail unit was here with
the residential above and the scheme
generally sort of updated and improved
the the building's aesthetics in the
street for take you then to the proposed
layout you'll see that it's very similar
to the scheme approved on appeal
the changes so you still got the amenity
space to the front here and the parking
adjacent to it this building in terms of
footprint is not altered there are
slight changes so this bin store is
repositioned to the boundary here and
this changes to the parking layout
there's a mini T space here that wasn't
provided for in the in the appeal scheme
and take you to the post elevation again
just to give you a flavor there are a
number of elevations provided with the
application but again this is just
showing for comparison the front
elevation and again it's very similar to
the appeal scheme the scale and form of
the building would be very similar minor
changes including changes to the
position of some windows and doors and
the scale and position of some of the
balconies has changed but overall
aesthetically it appears very similar to
that that has an approval one of the
changes would be the removal from the
scheme of the ground-floor commercial
use and the increase in number of
residential units and the size of those
on the site so the appeal scheme allowed
eight one bed flats and two two-bed
flats with a ground-floor retail unit
and the current proposal is for eleven
to bed flats eleven car parking spaces
are proposed which would equate to one
per flat and this is considered
appropriate in this location in the
course of this application submission
national policy change with respect to
affordable housing and all major
residential schemes which are schemes
over ten units are now required to
provide ten percent affordable housing
the applicant has submitted a viability
appraisal which looks at the finances of
the development and this has been
independently tested by the council the
result of this assessment concluded that
the site could make a financial
contribution towards affordable housing
equate into some thirty two thousand and
you'll see and that the applicant has
agreed to this contribution which would
be subject to a legal agreement the site
is within the Hockley Area Action Plan
where policy seek to ensure that the
viability and vitality of the town
center is protected the proposal removes
any commercial use in the building and
the applicant has therefore been
required to demonstrate that it would
not
viable to retain such a use at ground
floor the applicant has submitted an
updated viability appraisal which
concludes a scheme would not be viable
with the retention of a commercial unit
the completion of the scheme is
considered important in this location
the site is a prominent position in the
town center and the proposed residential
use would be an appropriate use in the
town centre given and given the
conclusion of the submitted viability
appraisal it is considered that the
current scheme would be acceptable here
the proposal would have no greater
impact on residential amenity than the
approved scheme and the building's
external appearance would be slightly
different to that approved but
considered equally acceptable the
recommendation is one of approval
subject to the stated conditions and
securing the section 106 leave agreement
for the financial contribution to
affordable housing
I think Thank You Katie apologies if I
repeat some of the stuff that you've
just gone over good evening my name is
Jonathan browning applicant and owner of
22 main road hopefully along with my
father john browning the site is disused
for compare disused commercial building
and not open to public since 2013 which
has operated out of their Portsmouth
office since 2016 the application was
expansion to 11 residential units
planning is originally in place with
previous owners for 10 residential units
Buster ground-floor commercial yet the
plans with poor design with nearly a
third of the building as corridors and
would have not have been favored by the
fire officer especially in light of the
recent events I've revised the layout to
include a central staircase an
introduction of a list to rim lifts to
remedy this issue February 2018 before
purchases at property a pre-op meeting
was held with our original case officer
Robert Davis where he issued their
letter that Roger Council would have no
issue and would prefer a fully
residential 11 unit scheme the strength
of this letter enabled us to achieve
funding from our bank in May two
thousand eighteen we submitted all plans
and fees unfortunately from that point
on correspondence from the council and
the planning team was almost completely
Neil the rest of that year I have well
documented time scale of missed targets
and unanswered emails and calls for
myself to the council which has resulted
in this application only recently been
issued to members' some 15 months after
the original target decision date of the
15th of August 2018 in effort to help my
situation Mike France forum members and
Ministry of Housing have also been made
aware of the delays and have our Shaun
squattin supervisor planning team
accordingly during our application the
MPP F updated their policy in July 2018
meaning that this application would now
fall under the 10% affordable housing
criteria this was not achievable as no
housing associations wanted a unit
within this scheme however a
contribution figure 32,000 was sought
and we did into into a 106 agreement
it's taken the council until August this
year to get to this stage unfortunately
it has been well documented the delays
and stress caused to our small family
business results in my father
hospitalized I've also pleaded with
multiple officers to involve to get its
application plated as a layers of course
crippling financial issues the loss of
the 11th unit to the commercial would
result in the collapse of our company
and the bank seized in the property this
will result in effectively an eighty six
thousand cell deficit plus fifteen
months of extra in extra interest
secured it has a huge knock-on effects
to the rest of the building's progress
as this unit would house electrical gas
intakes and drainage systems all of
which can't be determined until we can
ascertain what the layout of the unit
would be the true cost deficit to our
business is estimated to circa 200
thousand apologies to talk about figures
but this really affects us we have
actively sought to find an interested
business to occupy the commercial unit
since last year this is working on the
worst case scenario only one company
approached us to turn the unit into a
coffee shop but it was not large enough
for him to operate out of and also had
insufficient parking on the site
we currently have four interested
parties that would like to purchase
flats off the plan the issues that none
were none of which will commit to
purchase until they know the outcome of
unit 11 comments have been of a similar
nature that whilst they appreciate the
high street living position of the
building they do not wish to purchase a
mixed occupancy building that will be
subject to foot traffic noise and
privacy issues it has been highlighted
both at there are the other options for
small businesses owners to occupy like
the empty computer repair shop opposite
the site which has stood empty for a
year access to the site is via a private
road which serves two other properties
both house elderly retired couples who
have expressed deep concern as they do
not wish for a commercial unit to be in
place they have suffered for many years
of illegal parking and abuse of the
private road whilst the building was
under the commercial use there are many
pictures to show blocked driveways
blocked fire access regardless of the
clearway signs I hope you meet him allow
me to better inform everyone that the
true cost and betterment of the scheme
that a commercial unit would bring as I
feel the officer recommendation
while some appreciative appreciative of
its does not paint a true picture the
history surrounding the application
and/or future implication that a
mixed-use building would bring whilst I
understand the current highest reissues
and
to small businesses I'd ask you to think
of the catastrophic outcome it would
have to mine and my father's local
business thank you for your time
thank you Jeff
I obviously appreciate the delays that
have had had happened tonight I know
that this has been through staffing
issues at the council so on behalf of
the council we apologize for that
however this site needs one of the
things that really irks me about this is
that this is in the area Hockley area
action plan which is still part of the
core strategy of the council and one of
the things that is very prominent in
that is the retention of commercial and
retail use now one of the things that
has actually been cited many many times
is that this building was empty and
unused for a period of time which it was
however as far as I'm aware there was no
marketing done of it as offices or
retail at the time this was always the
intention to redevelop it if you look at
Hockley as a center it is a very vibrant
Center there are no office areas that
are empty there are a couple of shops
one of which I know is empty because of
a landlord issue but the demand for
retail space and commercial space in
Hockley is high and is good now
considering that we have why this
development lost a huge amount of retail
and commercial space when this went to
appeal originally I think in mitigation
of that one of the reasons being why it
was actually approved by the inspector
was because of the inclusion of the
commercial space and to say that now
that is not viable I think it's just
pointing to the fact that this was
always going to be the
the intention of the applicant to get so
far and then ask for a change of use now
one of the things that's actually been
produced recently from the applicant is
a rebuttal on the the review and it
basically gives lots of information on
the finances now if you actually care to
look through those one of the things
that becomes obvious is that although
the applicant has made it very clear
that he's going to have financial
difficulties of it the financial
difficulties are not the fact that he's
going to lose money on the site just
that he's not going to get the level of
profit that he wants on the scien
because he's looking at an eighteen and
a half percent profit on the site which
is what he's actually in his document
but his losses would be covered by that
now I consider that there is something
which is a commercial issue and the the
way that this has actually gone through
in the first place where it looks pretty
obvious that the the intention right
from the word go who has been to get it
to this stage and they're not for a
change of use and considering that it is
in the hockey area action plan where
there is stated intent for keeping and
developing retail and commercial use
there is nowhere within the hawk the
area action plain where the loss of this
commercial space can be recited there is
nowhere so once it's gone it's gone
and that is contrary to the hopefully a
reaction plan which is on their core
strategy I feel very sorry for that
player because they're not making the
money that they they think they should
do but I'm sorry it contributes it
contravenes out our actual policy
thinking I agree with it sir
my my concern on this this particular
property is the parking issue I'm very
concerned that they've only ended up
with eleven parking spaces
I think the eleven you said four
11 mm flats so if you having 11 clubs 22
parking spaces I noticed in the in the
report it said somewhere that obviously
you can go down to 11 because it's
plenty of parking and hopefully then
they will be only which is obviously is
chargeable also the private road I'd
like to know who's going to look after
the private road is it going to be the
residence of using the road or is it
going to be the people who built the
building and the other thing I have
noticed there is going up that private
road there is a post there that you
can't go through to the development of
bits Lane I want to make sure that that
will always be there because there are
car spaces behind that building that are
for the residents and my concern would
be people who are using or buy these
flats will end up using those parking
spaces without knowledge that's just
important Thank You chairman I think in
just having to make sure members focus
on this what we've what we've got is a
site which has a valid planning
application for essentially what we are
seeing the difference is the retail so
effectively all all other issues are
dealt with
it's just whether we think the retail is
acceptable in this so I think it's fair
to focus members just on to that part of
the argument councillor Stanley we are
constantly seeing our town centers
losing commercial space and we are
trying to encourage the entrepreneurs to
come in and use with that commercial
space and if we start losing it then
we're going to find ourselves we just
flats up and down the high street and
that's not good that's not good for the
residents and that's not good for the
for the whole community president this
commercial space you know is it's really
is what we want to see we want to see a
more vibrant High Street if you like and
we are we are trying to plan through
councillor Watson to to put this in in
in place not only embrace but hotly
Rochford and so on because if we are to
expand we need those commercial places
in place so that they can people can go
in and buy whatever they need in the
high street if we start to lose them
then one freight will be everybody would
be getting in their cars and going out
to other places so I I fully support
this if there is going to be a motion
that for commercial space then are fully
supported thank you like to make any
point on make some points on what's been
said I think there was a couple of sort
of clarifications in relation to sort of
the private road who maintains it those
sorts of issues obviously it's private
so it would be down to the covenants
that exist so that would generally be
the whoever has an access over that but
it's not something that planning would
get involved with in relation to that
that post you referred to and that's
outside the application site so it's not
something we can look to control through
this application but equally there's no
mention that that would be removed in
any way it's not in the application
sites not in the applicants control
either I don't think there was any other
specific questions
thank you
so just want to exercise is against
policy it the hot key error action plan
does seats maintain a vibrant sort of
commercial high street that is part of
that plan clearly this application is I
think different to other sites in the
Hockley area hopefully Town Center as
councillor Eve said the town center is
vibrant you know there's not very many I
think one was mentioned and I think it
might be opposite the site vacant unit
so there's lots of activity this site is
somewhat unusual and that it it's it's
seeking to redevelop the whole so what
we don't want is this site sort of
standing undeveloped for any length of
time that's not going to help out the
high street I think members need to come
to review as to whether the information
that the applicant has submitted is
sufficient obviously officers have
accepted that it would not be viable in
this case to provide the commercial unit
at ground floor and that if you like is
sufficient to guard against sort of
similar proposals we say in the high
student that would cause further
detriment in terms of loss of commercial
space so on balance officers are
recommending approval this scheme does
have lots of positives in terms of
redeveloping a site providing
residential which would draw people into
the town center and help contribute to
the vibrancy but not I albeit not
retaining any commercial use final
council Weston I'm just going to come
back to that private road obviously if
you do have more flex downstairs you're
going to have more more cars on that
private road there's a yellow line as
though is for no parking if it's a
private road I'm just wondering who's
put your line down there links it
wouldn't be as excited not really
question applicant after their after the
meeting members I think it's it's it's
where you lie on this one I think the
officers have
they feel that on balance that the this
is acceptable so without further ado
we'll go to the motion it's printed for
approval on 10-point to 14 can I ask
those members in favor of the approval
to indicate six six six those against
six seven that item is not approved can
I ask for a member to to take this
forward
councillor eaves on the basic principle
that is against core strategy on the
hopper your action plan and therefore
the the exclusion of further retail with
that okay okay thank you
so we have an was anyone you can say
Western seconded it
so does anyone wish to discuss that any
further go straight to the vote then
those members in favor of rejecting it
based on the failure to meet the
strategies policies that the council
have as as outlined those in favor of
the rejection please indicate seven
those against
thank you that item is rejected
thank you very much members just after
10 past 10:00 meeting closed
sorry
yeah let's reject it yeah